me
i love the title enemies by faith lovers
by choice
it's so sick
oh beautiful
beautiful well done
i give it to you for free share this
masterpiece to the world based thank you
kind stranger
i don't have to pay you the rule is if
you make me laugh i have to pay you on
the daca rooney's
side be like that's hilarious
sorry if you
if you laugh you get a pay cut that's
also the deal
hundreds gathered today to say their
final goodbyes to this fallen louisville
police officer no
mega doo doo
oh
god
gathered today to say they're finally it
was so much better than i thought
louisville police officer d d
mega
it's not funny though someone died
that's why it's funny it's so horrible
ah
min daniel that was worth it
oh no it wasn't don't cancel me please
listen
i just want to laugh it's been
scientifically proven that if you laugh
at edgy jokes it means you're better
capable to deal with hardship in life so
therefore
you can't cancel rest in peace grandma
you lived a long life but you're dead
now
rip grandma grandma the industrial
revolution and its consequences
made this clip not fine
hell
[Applause]
yeah but why he do it though do you ever
think about that if he didn't do it
he wouldn't be here right now why he
gotta do it man why did you throw away
selfish prick
oh you goddamn wanna go down can you go
downstairs
[Music]
no that does not count fine uh masterer
money coming
money go
go
ah that looked like it hurt fine scolder
fine has anyone ever told you you sound
like jacksepticeye no god the classic
wow no i get it never people just say
they sound like markiplier
you sound a lot like pewdiepie i'm of
course skeptical because i've been on
the internet for a while
um
yeah i'm just gonna say hey man i really
appreciate your content you've gotten me
through some tough times and i respect
the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i don't see anything
oh that guy still gets it the other day
doesn't count because i've already
participated but it's a funny claim well
i think uh first of all i think you are
i think probably you want to focus on
the
on the women world cup but i think
that's a good cringe love that oh can we
get a replay on the women's world cup
but i think
i mean how would you read those hand
movements
oh god this is rude even if i laughed
they just said no thank you no thank you
really just wanted you to cringe about
to hit a home run let's do it
oh god
wow
that's cute but i didn't
i did not barbecue cheddar pretzel nacho
yes my favorite flavor
baby
no
i
in 3d all right damn it you got me
[Music]
what a shark
damn nope
say hi to auntie charlotte
long before time had any the first
spinjitzu
that's good
totally caught me 100 off guard loved it
well done alvin say taiwan uh yeah very
nice
simon's ready to show me these
yeah man
no
let's just try to wreck them
oh is she okay i need to know grandma
okay otherwise ah
i have the worst since humor no ah thank
god they didn't leave their paypal i
don't have to pay them ah
he thinks you're dangerous what do you
think
i think you're trying to help
oh
damn it
that's pretty good
hey
uh leia pay earlier i'm helping fight me
damon get out of here brothers
[Laughter]
oh that's great great clip that's from
tiny tony i feel like he deserves a
shout that's funny
but like eva dick gets the money well
done what do you mean you lost the baby
go find it
good fair point you can do it you can do
i believe in you oh
i think this one is amazing
[Music]
what is happening
so good but no
no
babe
the optimum prado
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's pretty good
i love you she can't even like she can't
even look at it look at
beautiful 10 out of 10. simon well done
oh norwegian
i'm going to send you 99 instead of uh
you don't deserve it
[Music]
[Laughter]
cute
[Music]
all right that's it that's it i'm done
congratulations erg riper thanks for
sending all the clips that's really fun
oh god
i'm out traveling so therefore i don't
you know i don't need to applaud i don't
need to justify video there you go enjoy
it subscribe and you can win a billion
you could
see you next time bye